[Music]
my lips singing yeah yeah
Howie hey what's going on everybody for
first we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and then
the lead-up to Super Bowl 50 - this
weekend I'm joined by von Miller he's a
six-time Pro Bowl linebacker for the
Denver Broncos a Superbowl champion and
a big game MVP but how will he fare in
the hot sauce terror dome find out today
Vaughn welcome to the show I'm happy to
be here how are you with hot food I like
how for nothing Texas Dallas Texas you
know pretty familiar you ready to get it
going yeah I'm ready
[Music]
all right so this first one should be a
free-throw for you so it's not everyday
that we have a real actual chicken
farmer on hot one so I want to start by
taking it back to the Soto Texas where
you keep your 60 plus chickens was
poultry Sciences always you're calling
or just a way to pass while you racked
up wins for the Aggies it's not we're
taking an easy class you know what
collagen that's Tom build up cuz they
metal like this time this would be
another industry I'm like raising
chickens you know I guess it was
destined for me do you ever have any
problems with like predators anything
like that yeah we had a big owl problem
al got us for like ten Birds you know we
had we got like a net over the top just
coming straight through the net boom
straight through the net every time we
go out one morning and be a hole we have
fixed at home two days let it be another
hole three days after that is five or
six holes of top so he just now it's
like forget it just ruin it but yes it's
been good of what sounds net no do you
still dream of having a chicken TV show
where you have celebrities do voices for
the chickens and if so who are the
actors at the top of your list
yeah how you know about the chicken
cartoon yeah remember how babe the pig
was oh yeah yeah like you know the pig
is talking and you got the ducks and
stuff I would like to had that same
concept just around a rooster had to be
done
and this is Louisa mm-hmm classic so
with Super Bowl 52 on NBC just around
the corner I think it's a good time to
take it back to that fateful day two
years ago where you racked up your own
Super Bowl win and then MVP - boo who's
the first person that you called after
the win how do you call everybody my
phone went crazy
I still have messages on my phone and I
haven't read it from Super Bowl two
years ago my mom she was already there
my dad was there my brother was there I
really talked to anybody for like for
like two days
but if anything do you remember about
celebrating in flew away that night yeah
really already do information um Louie
was hosting a party we want so he's like
kids him at the club it was fun though
he was doing do you think that you
killed the dab you know a couple guys
bring it back but you know it was just
big at that moment and you know you see
guys like dabbing and doing all this
stuff you it's just naturally like man
he'll oh is he dead no more especially
with camp he dives after every you know
single play he had been killing
everybody all season so I guess it was a
little motivation for us to you know
stop that that uh big a
[Music]
I'm good I'm good
I know that you've described yourself as
the ultimate geek and he spent a lot of
time going down internet rabbit holes
and watching science documentaries do
you think that time travel is possible I
think it is
you can speed up Tom why can't you slow
down you travel at the speed of light
for almost a year out of space when you
come back but earth would have aged you
know ten years where you just aged one
year I mean these questions are way
bigger way over my head but I'm sure
it's possible if you can speed it up why
can't you we're very sort of slowed it
down
do you think that in our lifetime we'll
see a human colony on Mars you know
mostly about 2020 right well I mean I
believe them if you could take one
extinct animal bring them back and make
them an NFL mascot which one would you
choose and why the house eagle a che SS
of one of the biggest birds to ever roam
the earth legend that I used to snatch
humans in New Zealand and you know that
he was going to super walk so one I have
the Hass eagle is that's 30 times bigger
than them and then is there any part of
you that fears that advancements and
artificial intelligence may lead to some
sort of post-apocalyptic world where the
human race is just where the human race
is just ruled by cyborgs and robots also
like the matrix
yeah yeah I mean it's possible I mean
Sophie I mean that's crazy similar stuff
you've ignored and some of the jobs that
they have automating and stuff every
single year it seems to be you know new
advancements when it comes to AI think
this I mean a scary thing about but I
mean it's definitely possible
[Music]
these are big wings to turkey Lake Tokyo
real at first we feast we care way too
much about what our guests eat and I
know lots change for you since you're
reading chick-fil-a daily why do you
tell young players that a personal chef
is a better investment than jewelry and
nice cars mom I just try to give them
information I just try to suggest things
that I wish I would have known when I
was Rick I wish I would have had a chef
that cooked for me breakfast lunch and
dinner during the season and the
offseason because that's how you get a
hit that's how you play 15 16 years
staying healthy and eating right we got
to find out what time burgers eaten and
I mean I only get some rest oh and then
too because you know the personal chef
for the celebrity chef wave it's really
built over the last couple of years and
some of these guys even have their own
certain notoriety if you think about
Rick Ross's chef for Floyd Mayweather
chef have you ever had somebody's
personal chef make you a dish that made
you just want to poach their chef I'm
just a lawyer guy man I've been [ __ ]
over somebody house and they have a
great chef and the food was great
and I go back to my chef and tell them
what they had how they did it so I'm
just I'm just lawyer guy man the guys
that I got him around would
ghost pepper mm-hmm was that five that's
five is good though advanced we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that Grimm we do a deep dive on
our guests Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context I'll
just show you the picture and then you
tell me the bigger story does that sound
good okay all right
laptop please was it a sony fs7 right
there two three whoa you're into the
equipment here yeah when it comes to
like Instagram you know you can use that
platform you can use that platform at
all type of ways and I'd like to use one
and create like little commercials and
stuff it's free and I can always you
know support myself on Instagram all
right first things first yes and I love
a week after we had won the Super Bowl
you heard about a Kanye West Side
Saturday night I off all right there was
a whole thing about yeah that was that
that was that day did you catch it you
know that no no I didn't catch know what
the backstage assistant she caught it
when I first went there buff about three
hours before the show started her hair
was like nice and makeup was nice she
bringing stuff in all cheerful she was
doing stuff for all the gods backstage
on by the end of the night her hair was
like you know messed up
you know she had mix when it was no no
she's like you don't even want to know
it's crazy back here and then I didn't
you get yourself in 50s side by Kanye
that night or and that's like a weird
story dude that's a weird story - I got
Kanye I really asked for autographs or
take pictures or anything like that but
you know Kanye yet saying I love and I
had extra pair of easy - I had - I had
the shoe in my hand but I'm I'm rushing
I really didn't even think about getting
a sharpie you know and I hate when
people bring me stuff - son and you're
not ready right okay I hate when people
ask for pictures and they're like yes
right is pitching okay let me get my
picture and they get it
hold on wait hold on one sec hold on
then they like take it you can see them
like you know shaking or whatever you
can see you're shaking they take
that was blurry oh no and that's to say
that's the exact same thing that I did
you know that Connie I found him he
didn't really want to do it liking
something easy he put in hand no but yes
honey and I gave him the shoe and I was
like do you have a sharpie he later be
like man did you know Kim was right hand
like they came with like do you have a
shot
did you gotta you gotta let yourself but
I'm like man I'm tripping right now so I
had like Ronnie get a sharpie and I hit
him I ran back and he like signed it for
me it was cool I wish I would eat that
Denver Nuggets I'm always there Rocky
that's my guy when he kind of caught me
off guard on this right I was sitting
you know in the bench regular you know
day at the Pepsi Center
first of all mascots aren't you supposed
to talk he came to me on the sidelines
Leigh come she's a shot I'm like what's
going on I didn't know what's gonna
shoot a shot a day and he's like don't
shoot the shot half-court I got ready
shoot the shot half Corey's like no no
turn around go it over what a showman
rock yeah I didn't hit it nobody I got
close I got close this is that famous
strip sack yeah just your say do you
have a favorite the first one of the
second one my favorite play actually
went on the sideline cam here tried to
he was he had tried to run me over like
the last minute and we kind of like
stalled out I think it was that was
probably like in the second quarter is
with so it was it was right at the
beginning of the game whenever you're
going to just elite quarterbacks
it's no coming town were they gonna
charge somebody on the defense cuz I've
seen cam run over the truck 50 million
guys and I was now for unit coverage and
I had turn around and I saw him last
minute here like a 10 yard running start
so to get that style out was was big for
me that was the biggest play the game
watch me
he's got a dog with Shaye's in a
backpack mm-hmm some heard you talk in
the past about how you had a hard time
fitting into the Broncos locker room
when you first got there it's obviously
changed a lot since what's your best
piece of advice to rookies on how to win
over veterans rookies pay attention
every guy that makes it to international
football has been the man at some point
to win over bits it's not play it you
could be the weirdest rookie ever you
ball out you make place right away and
everything gets to fall in line what's
the most clever rookie prank that you've
ever seen in Minnesota actually um they
have boxes of fruit snacks and each
field I wanted rookies range overweight
fruits next I thought that I thought it
was clear for me I really don't like
playing pranks on the rookies you know
I'm trying to earn over your trust and
then I then I prank you you know it's
just not you know it's not the easiest
way to make friends in a locker
[Music]
you smell though so now that you have
the Super Bowl 50 logo tattooed on you I
know that you have chip tattooed on your
shoulder do not many tattoos you have
you lost count at this point my hands in
my neck in my face my mom said I was
those places that you can't get it but
everything else pretty much what's the
last one you got all right I really
bounced around a lot tattoos hurt
tattoos hurt so I started tattoo and I
finished it like probably most later
what's the story behind the rooster
tattoo you have a rooster tattoo right
yeah so there's a [ __ ] blow money I win
a couple of win a lot of bits with a
tattoo and then you once tweeted about a
tattoo it's a watermelon slice a chicken
leg a dollar sign and a hater yeah what
does that mean what was that debt oh man
I was just a long night at the tattoo
shop you know 4 o'clock in the morning
come around your tattoo stops the low
but you just started eating stuff well
you know just I just really like the
pac-man theme it's got like a piece of
watermelon
chicken and like the ghost is like I
hate her so just something I just yeah
so you're eating yeah it's like it's
like I'm asleep like the pac-man just
come across yeah I got the loo right
there yeah the late ninth a 2-shot you
know some guys got meanings and they
could you know name tattooed know is
just a lifestyle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah he's not a euphemism so I hope you
had no cuts in your mouth make sure you
wash your hands
Oh a lot of things you got to watch out
on touching Africa listen I've been
there yeah
[Music]
so during the 2017 offseason you took a
trip to Europe where as I understand it
you know a couple dozen stops and
Drake's Boy Meets World Tour but Drake
song rings off artists live to you
Yosuke trying to get my tone BAE
yeah but not enough reviews 9 um turn
the oaks
10600 is at nine now you hear it when
you hear like love you know the blue
lights I type stuff is crazy
and then I understand that you're joined
on the euro trip to thought I'll back
from jr. what's his best quality as a
travel partner and what's his most
annoying habit a lot of pranks a lot of
jokes I guess you get you know you get
taught it after a while he genuinely has
a unique outlook on life same night I
get an invite to Drake's grotto or
Vaughn's Club 58 where do I go and why
there you go to drink grotto look some
it's in Calabasas Italy the basement is
in Denver you know it's in Denver I mean
the ours is open 24 hours but yeah if
you get the invitation the truth got oh
yeah you do that
[Music]
my lip singing da we yep
this songs will blow you away with a
bullet go
I don't know how you can enjoyed it this
crazy so sports style has become a genre
all its own and in recent years the
eyeglasses have really exploded in the
zeitgeist I know that you need yours but
a lot of these guys now are bust not the
glasses whether they have a prescription
or not so what I want to do is show you
some of the looks that have bubbled up
over the last couple of years I know
that you're all about the positivity I
don't expect you to play fashion police
but I am curious you know the looks that
you like the ones that you maybe leave
to your friends and then maybe we can
crown a king does that sound good
perfect
all right laptop please first things
first
Russell Westbrook what's the rest McGee
be king breaking down all types of
barriers when it comes to when it comes
to being an athlete and fashion Russell
a look like a a dress shirt with sleeves
cut off yeah I would wear it but Russell
make you look incredible it doesn't make
you look incredible up next Tom Brady is
nice I mean what can you say those
glasses I wouldn't worry I mean it's or
what negative can you say about Tom
Brady if you want to wear glasses even
wear glasses if we want to wear overalls
and rain boots if you do that you know
whatever he whatever he wants to do he
could be alright next we have Mary
Poppins ex-husband you know a camp he's
the king of Hesse I haven't even seen
him with the same look twice for ya Bron
Bron naught is the real king he was
really one of the first ones to start
wearing glasses - he'd been wearing
glasses since the get-go oh there's a
lot of guys just wait less it's just you
know for the outfit or you know costume
LeBron he's wearing rest for a minute Oh
who's at the top of glasses Mountain
what's burgers a kegger than the king
after
quarterback accepted oh alright alright
fine
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last one oh
you don't have to if you don't want to
glue down a little dab what a culture
it's generous generous Vaughn yeah you
got the baby day I got amigos down all
right all right whoa
touch it find it it's like doing the
cinnamon challenge actually I had a
friend that beat this in in each other
this is the craziest thing yeah plate on
the spoon a piece cool it was funny I
mean he was going through it but he he
ate it I never I've never seen anybody
he look like a cartoon like his oz was
rigged yes welcome to his ears and when
he swallow you can see just like the
it's like an egg they just went from
here and there like slower than window
so hard to swallow it he did I don't
know if I'm gonna do this though it's
hard any send each other wait y'all
ready all right cheers my man
go ahead go ahead Von Miller
[Applause]
Oh No okay shaking around in there like
it's salty it's crazy
alright Vaughn it's the fourth quarter
and time's running out but before we get
out we need a prediction for this Super
Bowl you've called Tom Brady the best
quarterback you've ever faced Gronk the
best tight end you've ever matched up
against and Bill Belichick the best
coach or the Patriots destined for their
sixth Super Bowl win or do you see an
upset on Sunday no page a week following
in the wind I'm like of course the
Patriots the Pacers did you better see
the game versus the jacks
he knows food ooh I don't know what they
got going on over there but they may
have got Kowski they have a hit Edelman
all year all right well you heard it
here first von Miller with the Super
Bowl prediction Sunday on NBC
Eagles Patriots now there's nothing left
to do but roll out the red carpet for
Yvonne this camera this camera or this
camera let the people know what you have
going on in your life I'm just chillin
thanks guys oh no I mean um none for me
in the name of our close on the quest to
get to Super Bowl 53 you know this
year's almost over okay this offseason
as hard as we possibly can and would be
a we be back
[Music]
how did you even make something like
this that's crazy
hey what's going on hot ones fans and
Sean Evans checking in if you enjoyed
the video do us a solid please subscribe
we're not above begging for clout over
here so you know what to do smash that
subscribe button with a sledgehammer who
appreciates you me